[Música]
há algum tempo eu participei de um
evento que provavelmente toda mulher que
tem alguma amiga que está grávida talvez
tenha participado também chama chá de
revelação já ouviram falar que acontece
nesse já de revelação se reunir seus
amigos amigas das pessoas que você quer
o seu lado naquele momento tão
importante que a gravidez
juntas as pessoas na sua casa um lugar
que for pra poder revelar o que o sexo
do bebê tem um ponto muito e cônico
neste momento quem já vou deixar de
revelação vai saber que o bolo
o bolo naquele momento onde a mãe o pai
vão revelar o sexo do bebê tem duas
coisas
se o recheio foi cor de rosa é uma
menina se o recheio é azul é um menino
lembra nesse momento né
chega a ser um pouco constrangedor em
algumas fases mas nesse momento é quando
começa assim sempre tem alguém na
família é aquela pessoa que nem deveria
estar ali mas tallyne por obrigação
ela chega no ombro do pai e na mãe
assim se for menino ele vai chegar vai
falar e se vai pegar todas se for menina
a mesma pessoa inconveniente vai chegar
no ombro da mãe do pai vai dizer nessa
vai dar trabalho né
é ali que a gente começa a construir
estereótipos de gênero e esse foi um dos
pontos pelo qual eu fui buscar inclusive
um pouco mais de conhecimento da minha
formação ea minha atuação hoje o
trabalho no mercado de comunicação e eu
comecei a questionar o que era de fato
feminilidade masculinidade que é
feminino masculino homem mulheres se
tornou uma salada de pergunta na minha
cabeça que provavelmente está na cabeça
de vocês também ainda mais os tempos de
hoje
eu me matriculei em conseguir entrar no
mestrado de comunicação e semiótica com
a santa ela em são paulo que estudou
semiótica sabe do que eu estou falando
e nesse curso todo entre
na fase de qualificação agora eu fui
estudar signos e eu não estou falando de
capricórnio em diárias
eu tô falando de significados de tudo
isso que a gente tem hoje sobre gênero e
um pouco dentro da minha formação uma
das coisas que eu tive muito acesso foi
de filosofia e um autor que eu conheci
com mais profundidade porque não lembro
dele desde a 8ª série foi a última vez
que eu tiver sucesso
foi uma pessoa que eu comecei a estudar
muito se chama renê de cates quem
conhece o mercado se vocês já viram um
meme dele rodando pelo facebook é aquele
maravilhoso que diz assim frio nunca
passo porque eu tenho sempre razão
o cara que inventou é toda a lógica e
razão ele também é o cara que criou o
plano cartesiano
lembro da 8ª série 4 que lembra o plano
cartesiano era uma metodologia que foi
usada não só por ele para achar a razão
e o certo e errado das coisas mas pelos
geógrafos historiadores que você achar
um ponto como uma batalha naval dentro
de um determinado espaço sem que você
necessariamente tem que tá lá pra ver
esse ponto
e aí que começa a nossa linha eu vou
trazer aqui um pequeno desenho daquela
8ª série pra vocês então vamos lá ser
lembrando que o plano cartesiano
seguinte ele tinha um eixo x eo y isso
aqui
o exercício que a gente vai fazer aqui
hoje é sobre como a gente vai entender a
construção dos estereótipos a partir de
decádas olha lá
esse lado aqui eu vou colocar o que a
gente entende como homem tá tudo o que a
gente entende hoje a figura masculina de
homem e do lado de cá eu vou colocar o
que a gente entende como mulher com a
primeira imagem de mulher que vem na
cabeça de vocês aqui em cima no eixo y e
professora de matemática
eu vou colocar o que a gente entende
como másculo
idade masculinidade e aqui embaixo eu
vou colocar aquilo que a gente entende
como vê a unidade e num exercício
imaginário eu vou pedir para vocês
pensarem em palavras e adjetivos que vem
à cabeça de vocês no primeiro momento o
primeiro instante quando eu peço para
vocês pensarem no adjetivo que seja
relacionado a um homem com
características masculinas
a primeira palavra que vem à cabeça de
vocês eu já fiz exercício algumas
dezenas de vezes principalmente com os
amigos em um guardanapo da mesa de bar
para tentar ajudá los a entender um
pouquinho estereótipo
na maioria das vezes as palavras que
caem aquisição é um líder é um provedor
forte mas há um ponto que eu peço que as
pessoas me dizerem uma palavra que vem à
cabeça dela quando fala sobre homens com
características femininas quais são as
palavras que vem na cabeça de vocês né
fraco afeminado
do outro lado quando eu peço para vocês
me falarem uma palavra pensarem na
palavra sobre mulheres com
características femininas
vocês conseguem imaginar na maioria das
vezes principalmente para quem não é
desconstruir dão a palavra que vem aqui
é doce delicada recatada do lar na
agência
da mesma forma quando a gente pensa na
palavra que vem na qual é a palavra que
vem quando a gente pensa em mulheres com
características masculinas que vem a
grossa
nós que graça se ela é chefe de alguém
ela é mandona bom olha eu usei meu papel
zinho cabul a aula e ao se voltar pros
light
eu trabalho num mercado que hoje tem
certa dificuldade de entender mulheres
em cargos de liderança no mundo todo
mulheres em cargos de liderança
representam 6% dos bots são mulheres que
de fato tomam decisões dentro das
empresas ea cada passo que eu consigo
dar na minha carreira eu vejo cada vez
menos mulheres
essa forma catequese ana de pensar é a
forma e as caixas de estereótipos e
clichês que tem feito com que a cada
passo que eu consigo dar eu começo a
enxergar cada vez menos mulheres ea cada
passo que um homem da ele também começa
a enxergar mais homens pensar de forma
artesanal a gente significa colocar tudo
o que a gente pode ser dentro de uma
caixinha e é isso toma aqui você nasceu
ganhou caixinhas estereótipos é assim
que você vai viver para o resto da sua
vida mas é a minha pergunta pra vocês é
alguém está feliz com a caixinha que
tiveram essas caixinhas foram ao longo
do tempo reforçadas pela publicidade
pela mídia pela novela das oito
por todos os programas de tv que a gente
assistiu pela internet
estamos em 2017 a gente ainda tem muita
coisa para mudar mas quando a gente olha
para o passado e começa a entender de
onde veio tudo isso a gente vai lá pelos
anos 50 como vocês estão vendo aí eu
mostro para vocês como que a publicidade
brasileira conversava com as mulheres
o ponto era você tem que ser
este bem pra agradar alguém não é você
pra guardar um homem agradar uma outra
mulher nunca pra só te agradar e ser
feliz com você está usando
é desse momento inclusive que vem o
ponto de que todas as revistas de moda
adoram dizer você tem que ter alguma
coisa nova todo mês
toda a estação mas a cada vez que eu
conversava com pessoas do mercado
publicitário sempre vem uma pergunta mas
passa quando foi que a publicidade
começou a usar o corpo da mulher como
objeto na publicidade para vender
produtos
essa marca na história da publicidade
não tá dentro da publicidade
ela tem um outro nome está dentro da
medicina se chama pílula
anticoncepcional
tem gente que toma ainda pílula
anticoncepcional por um lado se a gente
enxergar isso quando aquele naquela
época nos anos 70 como um momento de
independência da mulher
agora ela consegue controlar tem um
controle familiar melhor
ela tem uma liberdade sexual muito maior
até porque foi no mesmo momento em que a
onde aconteceu em dia a segunda ea
terceira onda feminista
se a gente chegar só por essa camada foi
um momento de independência e libertação
das mulheres mas não porque é o ponto
que a mulher passa a ter o corpo livre
prazer porque ela consegue controlar a
taxa de natalidade inclusive nesse
momento a gente começa a ter as pessoas
às famílias cada vez com menos filhos
esse corpo se torna espaço público que
até então tava dentro de casa e daí que
a publicidade e começa a fazer que tipo
de uso dessa mulher desse corpo como
vocês estão vendo aí como um corpo
desprevenido que a qualquer momento pode
ser invadido a todo custo para vender
qualquer tipo de produto tem uma
pesquisadora chamada célia celia matinês
ela é de barcelona e ela fez um trabalho
e pesquisou todo o mercado de luxo de
moda para entender um sintoma
acontece na maioria delas e ela deu um
nome pra isso se chama síndrome da
namorada mota ainda podem procurar
depois que tem a tese dela disponível na
internet
ela fala o seguinte que as marcas atua
com as marcas no mercado de luxo atuam
na segunda seguinte forma para
representar a mulher ela pega o corpo
dela joga é muito comum ver marcas de
moda e mercado de luxo usar só um pedaço
do corpo da mulher
isso quando não marca de calçado e
acessórios que colocam o corpo nu já
devem ter visto inclusive esse ano
reforçando ainda uma idéia é uma ideia
daqueles anos 70 da sexualização da
exposição do corpo feminino
mas gente a gente tá em 2017
só que a gente segue representando e
usando as mesmas fórmulas dos anos 70
quando a gente apresenta peraí mas sexo
vende
será que vende mesmo será que aquilo não
é na verdade uma tia uma ativação de
gatilho mental que faz com que as
pessoas sintam em uma reação à peça
publicitária mas não que de fato sexo é
o que vende
mas é um espectador não necessariamente
vender sair desse século 20
requer algumas mudanças para a gente até
porque caixas já não significam a forma
como a gente quer se encaixar em algum
lugar ou a gente faz parte de algum
lugar
até porque até como a gente viu a
pesquisa já tem muita gente que não se
identifica entre a ou b
e esse sistema binário é cada vez mais
fluído
ou como diria o fubá uma que é uma das
pessoas que mais entendeu a sociedade
moderna líquido que está evaporando
caixa não representa mais eu não quero
ficar mais dentro de uma caixa até
porque essa caixa não diz mais tudo que
eu deveria ser ou ter essa caixa tem
empurrado inclusive algumas discussões
para que se você não se encaixa no
sistema binário a sociedade deveria o
poder público deveria criar por exemplo
um terceiro banheiro
para elas porque elas não devem acessar
o mesmo banheiro que eu
o problema é que quando a gente fala
sobre isso pelo viés de que o medo das
pessoas de aceitar as pessoas que não se
encaixam no mesmo banheiro está
relacionada à segurança aos casos de
estupro
não tem como não rebater essa informação
com o fato de que 95% dos assédios que
as crianças sofrem dentro de casa ou de
alguém familiar alguém conhecido 95%
você tem realmente medo de alguém que
vai compartilhar o banheiro com você
será que essa caixinha de estereótipos
que a gente está criando de fato
representa o que a gente está chamando
de segurança tem gente querendo mudar já
tem mudanças acontecendo
quando você vê por exemplo uma das
maiores marcas de cerveja do brasil
botando um ponto final na forma como o
objetivo fica a mulher
a gente tem uma mudança até porque as
marcas vêm atrás disso
mas não pode ser a única mudança que a
gente vai ver no mundo na forma como a
gente tem desenvolvido a publicidade a
comunicação das marcas e o que eu chamo
aqui de viés de barreira que impede com
que as coisas que são ditas hoje de
mulheres e ditas de homem possam se
misturar e que um cara possa ser as
coisas ser e ter as coisas que uma
mulher tem ea mulher também possa ser as
coisas que os caras têm tem muita marca
hoje tentando fazer isso mas parece uma
máscara tem muita marca tentando colocar
a diversidade fazer aquele aquele que
tinha para falar sobre diversidade
mas quando você olha levando o tapete da
marca você percebe que ela não paga
salários iguais entre homens e mulheres
que ela não tem políticas de diversidade
então pra que está fazendo isso numa
campanha se você não consegue fazer isso
nem dentro da sua casa mas caras não vão
resolver o problema
esse problema tem que ser resolvido de
base quando em novembro de 2017
o dicionário define mulheres e homens de
forma
bizarras e vocês podem checar o
dicionário assim
dessa forma esses bolos esses recheios
de bolo não tivessem mais relação sobre
azul e rosa
as crianças podem ser o que quiser a
gente que está aqui pode ser o que
quiser a gente precisa de uma cor que
diga que a gente possa pode ser não
preciso de uma caixa de um quadrante né
cartesiano que digo que eu posso fazer
até porque quando a gente olha esse
quadro antic dessa construção catorze
ana eu também sou uma pessoa líder eu
também sou uma pessoa forte
eu também posso ter coisas que estão lá
do outro lado e tenho certeza que muito
cara que tá aqui também que algumas
coisas que a gente tem
mas essa barreira tem impedido a gente
de conseguir trocar e hoje eu quero
deixar um convite pra vocês porque a
gente elimina essa barreira daqui e que
em vez de barreiras a gente tem a pontes
que ninguém homens e mulheres até porque
entre ser homem ser mulher tem tantas
outras identidades de gênero ali no meio
que a gente não pode simplesmente dizer
que elas não existem ou criar um espaço
determinado para elas até porque não
temos mais quadrantes pra pensar
ele está evaporando gente esse quadro a
gente tem que deixar de existir proposta
daqui pra frente é que caras que estão
aí do outro lado tem um monte de coisa
que você tem que eu também quero
eu também quero ser assim como eu sei
que tem um monte de coisa que tem aqui
que eu sei que você quer
então vale muito mais a gente construir
pontes para se conectar e fazer uma
troca dessas referências até porque essa
vai ser só a primeira ponte que a gente
vai construir juntos um futuro que a
gente vai ter muitas pontes para
construir juntos
obrigada
[Aplausos]